♪ [music] ♪
- [Tyler] In the previous video,
we discussed how
asymmetric information
can lead to moral hazard,
which can lead
to people being ripped off,
which in turn can lead
to markets breaking down.
Now, there are two types
of potential solutions
to moral hazard problems.
First, since the problem
is asymmetric information,
you can try to make
information less asymmetric.
If both parties
have similar information,
then one party cannot
so easily exploit the other.
Second, if you can't get rid
of the information asymmetry,
you can try to reduce the incentive
of the agent to exploit
his or her informational advantage.
One example
that you're already familiar with
works along both
of these dimensions:
user ratings.
You can get ratings
for businesses at sites
such as Yelp and Angie's List,
and for products
at places such as Amazon.com.
Reviews give you more information
about a product or service,
and they help balance
the information
between buyer and seller,
thereby mitigating issues
of moral hazard.
Additionally, the existence
of these review sites
changes the incentives
for the sellers.
In our previous example
of the auto mechanic
we sketched out how your incentive
to get your car repaired
might conflict
with the mechanic's incentive
to milk you for extra money.
However, the mechanic also
has to think about her reputation,
which is what leads
to future business.
Previously, you might have told,
well, just a few friends
that you got ripped off.
Now, today, you can write
an online review
and reach a much larger audience,
maybe thousands of people.
A mechanic's online reputation
is important to her success
and provides an incentive
for her not to try to exploit
her informational advantage.
While review sites are great,
the market is continually evolving,
and some sellers try to fight back
by faking or manipulating
reviews or ratings.
There's some obvious examples,
like favorably reviewing
your friend's book on Amazon
if your friend reviews yours.
But there are more
subtle examples as well.
For instance, some universities
invite lots of applicants,
knowing they will reject them,
just hoping to boost
their rating for exclusivity.
Reviews are more trustworthy
if they come from third parties
who do not have incentives
to bias the review
one way or the other.
The magazine Consumer Reports,
for example,
has a reputation
for honest reporting
because it's a non-profit
and it accepts no advertisements
and no funding
from commercial sources.
But there's another problem --
it's hard to exclude people
from produced information.
Information is also
what we call nonrival --
nonexcludable and nonrival.
Do those property sound familiar?
Yes, information
has the characteristics
of a public good.
Click to go back
and review if you need.
It's hard for Consumer Reports
to keep the information it provides
to only those people
who buy the magazine.
If you hear that Consumer Reports
says that brand X of television
is the very best,
well you might use that information
even if you didn't buy
the magazine and pay for it.
In this case, we would say
that you are free riding,
using the benefits
of their research
and testing without contributing
to paying the costs.
Free riding is a problem, however,
not because it's unfair or unjust,
but because it means
that information provision
may be under-provided
in the first place.
As a result, there are fewer
trustworthy third parties
reviewing products and services.
So, review sites help solve
moral hazard issues
by both balancing the information
between buyer and seller,
and reducing the incentives
for the more informed party
to exploit
an informational advantage.
There are other approaches
that work solely
by modifying the incentives
of those people
with the informational advantages.
Let's take two examples
that might seem
completely different,
but are actually, conceptually,
pretty similar:
house inspections,
and second opinions from doctors.
When you buy a house,
you typically get a home inspector
to check out the house
and identify potential problems.
By law in many states,
these home inspectors
cannot also sell services
to fix any problems
they've identified.
This changes their incentives.
No longer do they have the incentive
to overstate
potential problem issues
to inflate the bill.
Similarly, when you go to a doctor
for a second opinion,
that doctor is simply
diagnosing the problem,
but not doing the actual treatment.
Just like with the home inspector,
this eliminates the incentive
to run up the bill.
Both of these examples
split the diagnosis of the issue
from the actual work
to address the problem.
So while the information
is still asymmetric,
there is less of an incentive
to exploit that asymmetry.
By the time you're ready
to fix the issue,
this separate diagnosis by an expert
allows you to have
much more information.
Maybe now, almost as much
as the service provider in some ways.
This video has covered
the various solutions
to moral hazard issues
in situations
of asymmetric information.
In the next video,
we'll take up
a different kind of response
to the asymmetric
information problem,
namely signaling.
See you then.
- [Narrator] If you want
to test yourself,
click "Practice Questions."
Or, if you're ready to move on,
just click "Next Video."
♪ [music] ♪